one two three four
porto pesi sul collo no scarcerata
questa sono cola sono cola ed oro vere
ma me l'hanno regalata i miei zii al
battesimo e quindi ho deciso di mettere
le collane del battesimo che comunque
sembra un po da trapper quindi è stato
un regalo lungimirante quelli dei mezzi
grazie zii comunque le indosso solo per
andare in contrasto con quel discorso
che avevo fatto nell'ostentare umiltà
ecco noi non ne ho stento umiltà non
stentiamo con l'anas e d'oro del
battesimo comunque parlando di cose
serie proprio nel video dove ho spiegato
come spendono i soldi anzi come non
spende i miei soldi ho accennato
al discorso del fatto che io non ho mai
speso niente in ca ga te ma ho sempre
cercato di investire quello che io ho
guadagnato a parte che avrei voluto
dirlo in quel video lì come ho investito
i soldi ma sarebbe uscito un video
chilometrico e nessuno si sarebbe
scartavetrato così tanti gioielli da
ascoltare un video così lungo dove parlo
di sta roba quindi ho preferito dedicare
un altro video parlando proprio del
fatto di quindi free jazz non spendi una
mazza in che cosa invece spendi tuoi
soldi oggi parliamo proprio di come ho
speso i miei soldi fino ad oggi speso
tra virgolette perché si tratta di
investimenti quindi con piu spendi per
fare un investimento in realtà poi sono
soldi che ti ritornano con gli interessi
ad alta comunque allora parliamo di un
discorso più ampio attualmente la mia
fonte d'introito principale non proviene
da dai video youtube in sé per sé quindi
dalla monetizzazione del video youtube
ma come sapete già credo perché avevo
già spiegato ma da tutt'altro visto che
negli anni ho sviluppato insomma ha
fatto crescere il brand fa vj e quindi
oggi ha una sua autenticità e quindi io
lavoro di più con gli sponsor
quindi per quello vi dico che youtube
non è più la mia fonte principale di
guadagno però lo è comunque in parte
quella il fatto però tutto questo
periodo in cui io
insomma ho lavorato in questi dieci anni
ho preso tutto praticamente tutto e l'ho
messo tutto completamente da parte tutto
raramente ho speso soldi in karate ok
raramente il massimo che ho fatto è
stato spendere per i viaggi che non è
buttare via i soldi anzi secondo me i
viaggi ti arricchiscono culturalmente
quindi per me sono i soldi meglio spesi
secondo me però comunque cercato di far
aumentare questo capitale di tenerlo il
più possibile da parte proprio per
arrivare a questo discorso che vi sto
facendo mettiamo via sta roba qua sembra
per il cui come vi avevo detto a mettere
tutta la parte è servito appunto ad
investire la maggior parte investimenti
l'ho fatta in cose più sicure ad esempio
l'immobiliare adesso poi poi arrivò
comunque il mio obiettivo era appunto
quello di diversificare cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che se tu prendi il tuo
guadagno e lo metti tra l'altro non
tutto perché non si investe tutto si
desse una parte ovviamente uno sceglie
quanto io ho investito intanto proprio
perché a me non me ne fregava nulla di
avere dei soldi da utilizzare
nell'imminente ho messo tanto anche in
beni rifugio quindi in cose che non
perdono valore ad esempio loro ok quindi
un po come mettere in cassaforte e nel
tempo sai che ce li hai quindi anche
questo è bene fare più diversifichi più
possibilità che le cose vadano bene nel
senso che è difficile che tutto vada in
malora qualcosa sicuramente sì ma
qualcosa qualcos'altro no quindi dove da
una parte c'è un ribasso da una parte
c'è un rialzo di interessi quindi se tu
diversifichi sostanzialmente una cosa
può andare più giù un'altra può andare
più su e quindi le cose si compensano
questo è l'obiettivo
ok ho sempre avuto questa idea ma già la
piccola non aveva neanche 18 anni che
già pensava sta roba
ho sempre avuto un'idea che secondo me
l'immobiliare è sempre stato un ottimo
tipo di investimento o acquistato quasi
subito la mia casa a milano oggi vivo
qua appunto in questa casa da circa
quattro anni e mezzo sono quasi 5 anni e
io l'ho acquistata l'ho acquistata che
era nuova l'avevano costruita da
pochissimo ci vivo io e in che modo ho
investito in questa cosa qua allora io
ho comprato sta cosa qua a milano tra
l'altro costano tantissimo le case
questa casa qua va bene per al massimo
due persone io non ci potrà mai fare una
famiglia qua dentro perché è un po
troppo piccola attualmente sono 74 metri
quadri per chi vive a milano sa che 74
metri quadri non sono per niente può che
visti i costi però io nella mia testa
avevo tanto non ci dovrò vivere tutta la
vita ci vivo finché devo produrre
contenuti devo vivere da solo o magari
quando vivo con una persona non so
magari con vivrò con la mia ragazza qua
non lo so
ci si può stare se poi devo allarga la
famiglia un giorno non posso più stare
qua quindi devo cambiare casa e quindi
avere una casa più piccola è molto più
facile da affittare perché ovviamente se
ne hai una casa di 100 metri quadri e
passa cene voce deve andarci come una
famiglia intera qua invece la per
affittare studenti la puoi affittare a
una coppia la puoi affittare molto più
facilmente con meno costa una cosa più è
facile che te la prendano ok questo però
è stato un grande investimento perché io
innanzitutto in questi cinque anni non
ho pagato l'affitto io non pago affitto
e per farvi capire calcoli alla mano
l'affitto di una casa come questa dove
vivo adesso si paga su milano
all'incirca
1400 1500 rimaniamo sui 1400 facciamo un
po di meno ci sono dentro da
praticamente cinque anni quindi fai 1400
al mese per dodici quindi in un anno
sono 16.800 euro in cinque anni sono
84 mila euro quindi ho risparmiato solo
comprando la casa solo non pagando
l'affitto per viverci ho brevemente
risparmiato 84 mila euro ok e non ho
fatto niente ci vivo dentro e basta
quando io un giorno mi sposterò questa
cosa qua la metterò in affitto ok quindi
ci sarà una persona che pagherà a me
questo affitto qua che io non ho pagato
e che ci vivo perché la casa mia quindi
vedrete che l'investimento già torna
così inoltre e questa è la parte bella
secondo me di investire in immobili per
quello che io cerco di farlo i nein
sull'immobiliare con la tua acquisti una
casa quindi spendi che ne so 400mila
euro per un appartamento è difficile c'è
dipende poi ovviamente dove lo compri
però tipo in una città come milano è
difficile che perda valore quindi una
casa che vale così tanto un domani
dovrebbe valere addirittura di più
quindi domani se la vuoi di vendere tra
dieci anni la rivendita di più di quanto
l'hai comprata quindi magari 20450 500
dipende come va il mercato comunque
dovresti almeno rivenderla quanto l'hai
pagata questo sicuramente specialmente
su milano quindi tu hai guadagnato nel
mentre dei soldi di affitto e in più i
soldi che ha speso non è che non li
prendi più di poi sempre di avere
rivendendola casa questo secondo me è un
buon modo di investire poi ovviamente
non è così semplice ci sono tante cose
devi starci dietro di stare attento a
chi metti in affitto
tante cose qui non è così fa non è che
schiocchi le dita e lo fai per o
comunque è un concetto che ci sta ho
fatto queste cose per più appartamenti
ok quindi non è l'unico appartamento che
possiedo questo suo milano andando
avanti ci sono anche altre cose come ad
esempio investire io con la mia banca
invece in titoli ok quindi la mia banca
si occupa anche di fare investimenti con
il mio capitale che non è fermo nel mio
conto ma genera profitto con i titoli
non mi soffermo molto su questo
argomento ragazzi perché non mi intendo
troppissimo di borsa diciamo che è una
cosa che mi viene più gestita a quella
per quanto riguarda immobiliare invece
ci metto un occhio di riguardo anche io
sull'immobiliare in particolare dovresti
guadagnare sugli affitti normali circa
il 4 per cento mediamente all'anno di
quello che tu hai speso ok quindi ogni
anno dovresti entrarci le 4 per cento
quattrocento ogni anno 300 ogni anno
finché non rientri del tuo
del suo investimento totale
invece sui titoli attualmente io prendo
non mi ricordo più però sul 77 per cento
quindi anche di più però anche vero che
sono robe un po più a rischio quindi più
uno guadagna gene più uno rischia quindi
bisogna anche se tanti attenti su questo
una parte molto più piccola rispetto a
tutto questo quindi la minima parte ho
deciso di investirla anche in cripto ma
proprio molto molto molto meno perché
ovviamente non si sa bene come va come
vanno le cose però ho deciso di avere
anche delle clip perché visto come
stanno andando le cose non si sa mai che
in futuro diventa tra importanti già lo
sono ma in futuro magari diventeranno lo
diventeranno molto di più e tutto porta
a pensare che lo diventeranno e quindi
ho deciso di dire sai che c'è per
diversificare ancora di più oltre a beni
rifugio
immobili
titoli
ho deciso anche lì sì un po in un cripto
e quindi di prendere una parte piccola
ma di prenderla e di metterla in bitcoin
in particolare coin e tir hume e altre
monetine più piccole però l'ho fatto non
le vendo quindi non voglio fare
speculazione su sta roba le tengo
proprio negli anni fino a che i bitcoin
non si esauriranno proprio e io avrò un
bitcoin insomma avrò qualcosa da parte
che potrebbe avere come non valere
questo non lo so però l'ho voluto fare
dovuto tenerli quindi a lungo termine
quindi non ho bisogno di studiare
l'andamento per fare speculazione non è
quello che non mi interessa comunque
ragazzi tra parentesi apro una piccola
parentesi io sono uno youtube era e non
un consulente finanziario quindi tutto
quello che ho fatto lo faccio perché
credo che sia giusto ma ognuno ha le sue
idee e non fate mai cose sono siete
sicuri di quello che state facendo
quindi non sono un consulente
finanziario sono youtuber quindi non
prendetemi come esempio per fare le cose
ognuno fa quello che vuole chiudo la
parentesi perché era giusto specificare
questa cosa ai ragazzi spero che video
vi sia piaciuto quasi conclude insomma
di oggi lasciate un commento su insomma
le vostre eccetera
iscrivetevi al canale e noi come sempre
come sempre ci rivediamo si trova il
telecomando ad un grosso vito bella
ragazzi
[Musica]